would you rather always have Bo and not
know it or always smell Bo on everyone
else oh this just a theime convention
experience isn't it I don't mind the
smell of Bo much it depends on the
Bo Nasty ones but I generally don't mind
it I've smell some dank Bo before dep
how close I am like if I'm not that
close to you I don't really care if you
Bo but if I'm like if I'm like this and
I get a proper W I'm like oh [__] no
have you not smell some BO that is just
like Rancid
it literally smells like trash okay
actually there's one or two times I can
it's main like when someone it's rare
but there are some where it's like God
damn my first is not that bad is minor
is is like I'm fine with I'd rather not
subject other people to
me as someone with Dank Bo yeah yeah I
mean okay what if what if you have like
the worst Bo in the world and like you
have like
the the the stinkiest [__] Bo you can
imagine okay here's the question though
right if you selected the second option
of always small be on everyone else that
doesn't necessarily mean you also won't
have
Bo right well presumably you wouldn't
have Bo because the option is having Bo
yeah right but it didn't specifically
stay that so I needed to make
sure uh yeah I think I'd rather smell bi
also you might be like people won't want
to hang out with you if you stink I I I
can tolerate other people I don't mind
you know what I mean I'm ch CH but you
would be you know you'd lose friends
possibly I always do small B on everyone
else anyway like in real life so I'd
rather just do that I always SM as well
that's my problem all right would uh
would you rather lose all your friends
but keep your BFF or lose your BFF and
keep the rest of your buds ooh so would
you rather have one and only one really
really good friend or never have a
really really good friend but just a lot
of like rather keep the BFFs medium
friends yeah yeah yeah I'd rather have
the BFF I think you only need a few very
very close friends in your life uh I
mean obviously having a lot of friends
is definitely an extra and is cool but
you know having that one just sometimes
having that one friend that will come to
you whenever you need or yeah whenever
you're in the time of need that's what
you need most in life yeah I think
that's an easy question yeah this a good
WR would you rather walk in on your
parents or have them walk in on
you have you ever walked in on your par
[__]
uh don't think so I did when I was a kid
oh yeah it was
unfortunate why do you say it like it's
like a traumatic event because it was a
it is it is every time every kid if for
for any kid it's a traumatic event if if
it happened to me it would be a
traumatic event for me as well um so
which one would you rather I don't know
both are like equally traumatic the one
is like do you want to subject do you
think your parents would okay here's the
thing here's the thing okay why you got
to look on your face if you get walked
in on would you choose your mom or your
dad if you had if if oh to walk to Walk
in walk in on you oh Dad 100% my dad
would be like yo he'd stand over
me consume child imagine your dad
walking in on you like you'll be
stronger after this Boy Lo the [__]
door you
can you'll be like that that's weak cuz
I feel like okay here's here's the thing
if my dad walked in we would have the
acknowledgement to like never talk about
it okay I mean my dad's walked in on me
Jack most guys pick their dad right so
that's an easy call but which one would
you rather you walk in on your parents
or your parents walking on you I think
which parent are we talking about that's
why I asked both both the same both of
them at the same time coming in I feel
like if both walk in that's better than
just my mom walking in you my dad would
just your mom walks in
okay both if both my parents walked in
my mom would be like what the [__] and
my dad would be like let him cook
hold up my dad would make the situation
bearable hold up let him
come God my bum would be like so we we
need to like sit down and talk about
this so which one is it you walking on
your parents or your parents walking on
you I think I'd rather have them walking
on me I think I'd rather have them
walking on me yeah because then it feels
like it's the natural circle of life you
know they they're like cuz they parents
they understand you got you got to do it
if I walk then I'm like dude you've
already done it I'm already here you
pack it up yeah
I feel like I I would be I would feel
less bad if they walked in on me than if
I walked in on them I think they'd feel
way more embarrassed than I would I
don't know I don't know what this is
about me but I think be like ah whatever
I think most people would take getting
walked in on by their parents over
walking in on their parents I don't know
everyone I've talked to uh that has
walked in on that's if you have chill
parents though you have like really like
annoying parents or parents that are
like not good they' be they'd like
always bring it up or something be would
they I don't think they would they might
I don't know man you have good parents
my parents never brought up what about
getting walked on by but it remains in
my memory forever what about getting
walked in on by a sibling I I'm asking
this question cuz I can't answer this
question I think I would rather have my
parents walking on me to be honest would
you rather have your parents walking on
you or your sibling but it's different
right cuz he has Brothers oh you have
brothers and I have a sister so if I had
a brother I think I'd be like whatever
about it but with a sister that's just
[__] awkward as [__] like I would I
would rather with Brothers it's like
it's all about having one up on each
other the brother walks in you he's kind
of got one up on you he's like I've seen
it oh he can blackmail you now yeah he's
got no game i s you know what I mean
tiny I see the genetics didn't go to
you yeah where like the sister I imagine
you can be like I'm so sorry that was
really F be like I don't even want to
imagine that yeah so yeah definitely if
my brother walked in he he'd probably be
like low you shout it like loser tell
the whole
house would you rather be in history
books for something terrible or be
forgotten completely after you die I
think I'd rather be forgotten completely
after I die yeah I guess this is just do
you have an
ego it's it's the question of how famous
do you like how famous are you willing
to be I mean yeah I'd rather just
die terrible cuz then my family would
have to deal with it how terrible are we
talking oh [__] how terrible are we
talking yeah
pretty [__] think of every terrible
person you've learned throughout history
there's never been someone like in a
history textbook who's like I mean what
he did wasn't that bad you know it's
always something like what the hell
there is but I mean yeah but then not
the ones that are remembered right the
ones that you remember the most are like
the really really all right but what if
you were just remembered for being like
Mega
cringe like not not even like not even
like doing something name me someone in
a history book that is Mega
cring this is just like asking would you
rather have a super cringe life or die
and no one else remember that you were
super cringe obviously I would just
rather not be cringe no I like cuz yeah
I do want I do Wonder historians please
please tell me who is the biggest clown
in history right well I mean there's a
lot surely there is there's a lot of
clowns but I don't think the concept of
cringe existed you know Joey the the
concept of cringe is always exist we
don't remember cringy people we remember
awful people and heroic people we don't
we we kind of don't I'm I'm now I'm just
wondering how far does the power of
cringe take you not generational it's
not cringe is not generational do you
think Henry VII was pretty cringe yeah
but he was more of a horrible person
which is what he remember yeah but no
one was like my Lord that was pretty
cringe okay okay but if but if people
would say if people could they would
definitely [__] say that are you
kidding me are you absolutely kidding me
my Lord that was an L my Lord
this is going in the cringe
collection this is going in the cringe
collection unfortunately if you called
him cringe uh you would have just gotten
[__] beheaded at the time but like if
you could I mean that's some we look
back on it that's someone who would have
been in the history books he got
beheaded for calling the cringe kind I
think that's what some of his wives did
to actually that's the real
reason his wives died of cringe like
Henry Henry you're you're like being a
bit cringe right now Henry I'm not going
to lie kill them
behead them for pointing out you
literally creating a new [__] state
of religion just uh so you can get
around divorce laws Henry that's a
that's that's pretty cap that's a little
cringe Henry that's cap Henry come on
now people are cringe yeah let's just go
through British history and oh oh like
who who is that person that gets
remembered for being like the biggest
like incest you know talking talking
about cringe like the biggest like
genetically incestral like baby that has
ever been born or something it's one of
the Kings right yeah it's one of the
Kings right is is it like the Russian
family no am I crazy is it the Russian I
thought it was a British one was it I
thought it was fren who's the most
anestrous personaliz we all have we all
have different kind why does g know this
off by heart given his
texes the most in there we go the cult
Clan oh I have seen a video on this oh
no this is going to a complete this
ising this is day this is modern day
yeah I I was thinking of like royal
family where you see who's the most
incestous royal family member why are we
googling this what's wrong with us just
just curious I'm just curious because I
don't knowen I don't know anything about
anything else about what these people
did aside from the fact
that King Charles of Spain well we were
all wrong rotting insides jeez oh the
habsburgs oh of the 11 marriages during
the reign of the Spanish hbgs only two
were not incestous God damn the history
is super interesting by the way I watch
a bunch of videos about it it's very and
they're also famous for the jaw seen the
jaw go to go to type in the Habsburg jaw
you just go to Oh no just click images
you'll yeah just click images and you'll
see
okay yeah like it's literally the first
thing that comes up oh it's this it's
this dra right right right right God
damn this I you know this I this I feel
I don't know anything else about the
history of this aside from the fact that
hey this is this is pretty
cringe that's all that's what I was
trying to say you know is this where the
Giga Chad meme started no that's not
gigachad I'm like hey this is uh this is
incest uh pretty cringe right that is
pretty cringe that is pretty cring why
is Mark I don't know why Mark
Zuckerberg's there what the [__] wait
does he have it no no he doesn't so why
look at that side profile on the second
image jeesus there's no way that's real
God Dam that's like a Tik Tok
filter you know you know the yo the
Habsburg jaw filter my favorite on Tik
Tok